la voix de la liberté le
premier satellite terrestre du monde libre se fait entendre
dans le monde entier captages scientifiques par
le réseau radio à piste minute et par d'
autres installations radio de la
tonalité régulière sur la fréquence approuvée du
comité pour l'
année géophysique internationale le satellite US Explorer
est  se faisant entendre
en orbite et à des altitudes de 230 à 1 600
milles à 18 000 milles à l'heure et ici
Pickering Van Allen von Braun, les
meilleurs scientifiques de l'espace qui transpirent
des heures, des jours et des années jusqu'à ce que le
missile marin Jupiter de l'armée lance sa
lune artificielle et avec  il a propulsé la
démocratie dans le travail d'équipe coordonné de l'ère spatiale l'a
fait de Huntsville en Alabama
à Pasadena en Californie, de la
fusée pionnière de redstone modifiée pour
la mission satellite au développement en quatre étapes
Jupiter C du
satellite en forme de balle lui-même combinant
toutes les capacités de l'industrie scientifique de l'armée
équipe et maintenant pendant que l'explorateur
effectue une orbite complète tous les  118
minutes racontons pour l'histoire cette
heure dramatique du décollage à Cap
Canaveral les nouvelles du jour vous ont montré
des lancements de missiles dans de nombreux numéros récents
mais ici vous êtes témoin d'un événement
dont
vos petits-enfants parleront avec une réflexion impressionnante en 1958
gratuit  les hommes partout ont levé leur regard vers le
satellite de la liberté
69 pieds 65 000 livres le
jupiter-c à quatre étages dans le PM les trois derniers
étages sont mis en rotation au décollage à
des fins de guidage un dîner spécial Buell
donne une plus grande poussée
en 145 secondes les 78 000 livres de
poussée de la première étape aura
soulevé le missile à une altitude de 53
miles l'ensemble du travail prend environ sept
minutes à ce moment-là les trois dernières
étapes auront été tirées en
succession rapide et le satellite accéléré
à la vitesse maximale pour l'orbite
enfin l'explorateur un  Une
balle scientifique de 30 et 8/10 livres bourrée d'
instruments commencera des
voyages autour du globe qui étonneront l'
imagination que
vous